[Musique]
le thème de notre rencontre aujourd'hui
m'a été donné en anglais
permettez que je vous la donne en
français c est s conseillé d'arriver
alors est ce qu'on y est arrivé
eh bien depuis toujours je pense que
l'humanité à aspirer à un monde de paix
de justice
ba aujourd'hui on peut se demander ben
oui est ce qu on y est arrivé ma réponse
va vous surprendre surtout dans le
contexte actuel
pour moi la paix est non seulement
possible
elle est inévitable la paix est en
marche
alors maintenant je vais donner une
explication de ma conviction quand
j'étais môme
j'avais un gros rêve là viennent de lire
c'était de visiter tous les pays du
monde et tous les territoires sans
exception c'est fait ça m'a pris plus de
50 ans j'ai rien fait d'autre dans la
vie j'ai carrément pris une vie
sabbatique le je suis parti de france 17
ans dieval en poche en 1955
je peux pas vous parler de ces années là
mais à l'époque on parlait pas un voyage
aventure on reconstruisait encore le
pays de la guerre on n'avait pas
d'information et moi j'avais pas de
moyens donc j'ai cru que ça restera un
rêve impossible est fou pourtant c'est
fait ça s'est fait en deux périodes
j'ai eu à mon premier voyage a duré 18
ans sans rentrer à la maison
ce qui va faire entrer c'est une
dysenterie pas soigné ensuite j'étais en
france et pendant 30 ans 30 ans je
partais chaque année six sept huit mois
pour finaliser mon rêve j'ai rien
planifié je dirai tout s'est enchaîné
malgré moi alors il ya un problème
enfin il beaucoup de problèmes quand on
voyage mais il y en a qui est important
c'est que c'est le problème de la
communication
j'ai donc passé les sept premières
années apprendre des langues en faisant
des petits boulots dans différents pays
d'europe
je dois dire qu entre l'espagne et
l'allemagne j'ai passé deux ans au congo
et pourquoi service militaire pour
éviter la guerre d'algérie regardez j'ai
pas une vocation de passoire ensuite
j'ai atterri au canada après bien des
histoires et je m'aperçois d'une pour
faire de l'anglais je m'aperçois que
d'une chose que je savais pas y'a pas
les guides de routards à l'époque c'est
qu'on paye plus en amérique du nord
qu'en europe
là j'ai enfin compris que je pouvais
économiser pour mon rêve et avec trois
ans d'économies à toronto j'ai tenu six
ans sans travailler c'est à dire le
premier voyage a duré de 55 à 60 13 les
six ans était de 67 à 73 et je dépensais
mes économies au compte gouttes
à l'époque le dollar par jour alors ça
pour deux raisons majeures une j'ai
jamais payé pour le transport et en tout
j'ai tout fait en stop
en tout 400 mille kilomètres c'est quand
même la distance de la terre à la lune
ensuite j'ai jamais dormi à l'hôtel donc
le dos là c'est pour manger payer les
visas mais même là je mangeais pas dans
les restants je longeais dans les
marchés les carrioles d'abord de route
une fois ya un camion qui veut passer
devant il a perdu des cordes sur 20
mètres j'ai tout ramasser et j'ai fait
le lapin pendant dix jours
faut pas être difficile mais ce qui
explique aussi le dollar c'est qu'il
faut comprendre que la plupart des gens
dans le monde ne peuvent pas voyager
donc leur façon de connaître l'étranger
et bien c'est de l'invité il ya eu un
tas d'expériences brièvement j'avais été
vif chez les hippies à san francisco
chez les bons à bangkok dans les écoles
de yoga en inde chez les coupeurs de
tête à bornéo j'ai travaillé dans un
kibboutz en israël
j'ai même été chez le fameux docteur
albert schweitzer à lambaréné au gabon
je me suis retrouvé aussi par exemple
cette fois en prison vous avez remarqué
d'excellentes gélard dangereux là
ah ouais j'ai failli faire flinguer
flinguer une dizaine de fois à défaut la
chance en face en face d'eux voulait en
fait vous avez un miraculé j'ai été
déporté plusieurs fois j'adore c'est
gratos donc
rires je vais arrêter là parce que je
prends raconter toute la nuit
je disais ça très brièvement pour vous
faire comprendre comment j'ai fait mes
humanités
alors vous êtes en train de me demander
mais pourquoi faire tout ça je me suis
posé aussi la question est la vraie des
vraies raisons sectionné avant la guerre
je précise pour les plus jeunes c'est la
deuxième non mais j'en vois qui calcule
l'eau et je dis ça parce que mes
premiers souvenirs de la vie c'est la
guerre et quand j'étais enfant par
exemple moi je faisais un cauchemar
récurrent
je me voyais devant un peloton de la
gestapo en train de me fusiller ça
commençait fort aujourd'hui 70 ans après
quand j'entends la sirène qui s'essaye à
la mairie de blaye daboussi là j'ai
toujours un pincement au coeur et mon
premier réflexe est de courir à la cave
me réfugier parce que pour moi ce bruit
dallas annonce les bombardements mais
alors ce que j'ai fait là on voit la
carte selon vous la voyez sur votre
gauche
le noir présente le stop en fait elles
rouge la partie france c'est pas c'est
pas un tour du monde que j'ai fait un
cercle
non ça c'est exact dans tous les sens et
j'aime mieux après ça plutôt un tour des
hommes
ce qui m'intéressait c'est pas le
kilométrage des aventures c'est le coeur
de l'homme
j'ai voulu savoir en rencontrant les
hommes du monde entier
mais est-ce qu'un jour les hommes vont
être capables d'établir la paix voilà
c'était inconscient départ je lave ou
mais c'était ça la vraie motivation
aujourd'hui il n'y a pas grand-chose qui
porte à sourire la paix et quand on
regarde le passé sanglant de l'histoire
on peut pas imaginer la paix en fait et
il est très dur d'imaginer pour une
autre raison on l'a jamais eue
on peut pas imaginer ce qu'on connaît
pas
par contre ce qui me disent que la paix
est impossible et regarde pas l'histoire
parce que dernièrement je vous signale
que l'europe a réussi à faire la paix et
quand on voit le passé de ce continent
c'est quand même un miracle
un autre exemple
par exemple on sait tous se balader dans
la campagne vous avez déjà vu sur les
ronces les chenilles s est pas ragoûtant
c'est plein de poils des grosses pattes
des gros yeux et l'as berck
mais si on ne savait pas comment
imaginer le papillon quête dans ce qu'on
a vu jusqu'à date de l'histoire de
l'humanité je dirais c'est la période
chenilles
alors j'avoue avec vous qu'il est
pratiquement impossible d'imaginer le
beau papillon de l'apec est dedans
mais jeudi 6h ni ya papillon le pour
rétablir la paix oui il ya une chose qui
est nouvelle dans l'histoire des hommes
seka plus de distance c'est nouveau ça
vient de sortir nouvelle est tous dans
le même bateau tout d'un coup pour la
première fois et ben je pense qu'il va
falloir en tenir compte tout simplement
alors il ya beaucoup de choses à régler
vous savez comme moi mais je pense que
pour que la paix commence à se dessiner
il va falloir il ya trois pas à faire un
pige et que la terre dès qu'un seul pays
quel titre de mon premier livre
d'ailleurs la terre n'est qu'un seul
pays deuxièmement comprendre qu'à qu'une
seule espèce humaine
une seule ou et voilà ce scientifique ah
ouais on est tous frères
partout le vainqueur et des sentiments
et on vit tous entre deux pôles opposés
commun la joie et la peine personne n'y
échappe
le huawei le troisième pas la tête le
plus important ce qu'il faut comprendre
c'est qu'il n'ya pas trente six
religions non
qu'est-ce que d'abord expliquer ce que
j'entends par ce mot là parce qu'il est
sensible religion je pense que la région
c'est tout simplement un code de
conduite qui expliquait à l'homme pour
trois raisons une pour le développement
personnel de ces valeurs et qualités qui
leur départ d'ozil deuxième pour le
vivre ensemble et la troisième pour la
préparation au monde suivant ce qu'il
faut comprendre c'est simple c'est
quelqu'un seul bouquin d'instruction
pour tout le monde depuis le départ un
seul bouquin mais ce bouquin comme tous
les bouquins il a beaucoup de chapitres
voilà le hic au fur et à mesure que
l'humanité progresse un nouveau chapitre
et additionnés pour les nouveaux besoins
et la nouvelle compréhension
oui et en fait l'enseignement spirituel
qui a donné aux hommes est progressif et
répétitif comme à l'école
un seul enseignement mais graduelle ça
l'air de rien ce que je dis là mais
quand on aura piget ça ça va terminer le
conflit entre les religions donc voilà
il y en a qu'une alors pour établir la
paix faudra un ami de paix on va pas
faire la maison nouvelle avec les
vieilles blick a donc ça veut dire que
il faut commencer par changer soi même
le on a la recette déjà pour faire la
paix a déjà été donnée ça vous faire
sourire peut-être moi je crois que la
recette c'est aimez vous les uns les
autres
il s'agit de l'appliquer tout simplement
mais ça ne suffira pas l'homme nouveau
l'homme de paix il faudra aussi
s'occuper du côté collectif et pour
sabah parce qu'aujourd'hui il ya aucun
système qui répond aux besoins de jours
il faudra donc un plan c'est ça que je
voulais dire eh bien voilà ce que j'ai
découvert
c'était la grosse découverte de mon
périple là c'est que j'ai découvert qu'
il y a un plan administratif mondiale
pratique pour gérer la terre comme une
seule entité politique qui a été révélé
au 19ème siècle en perse c'est ça que
j'ai vu et ce plan permet également
l'éclosion de cet homme une de paix dont
on a besoin
donc est ce que j'ai vu c'est que la
paix est en marche pas un voeu que de ma
part je vous dis ce que j'ai vu je
témoigne donc on peut dire oui ça y est
on y est arrivé un petit mot bref sur ce
plan il est demandé vous savez pourquoi
il est demandé à chacun de chercher la
vérité par lui-même
aïe aïe aïe deuxièmement on doit pas
être administré par un seul bonhomme
comme on fait on a toujours fait on
continue à faire parce que ça amène des
dérivés des dégâts il s'agira d'être ce
plan propose d'être administrée par une
collégialité de neuf membres disons par
exemple élu démocratiquement les neuf
ans de pouvoir
quand ils sont unis mais quand ils vont
à la maison personne investie du pouvoir
voyez le truc ensuite pour que ça marche
il faut que tout le monde soit éligible
ce qui a jamais été fait dans le passé
ce plan fait et inédit a jamais été
imaginé et dernière chose pour que ça
marche
propagande électorale interdite voilà
c'est ça que j'ai découvert
maintenant je vais vous quittez ans et
pour vous remercier de votre aimable
attention je vais vous citer une maxime
de l'auteur de ce plan il dit
la gloire désormais n'est pas pour celui
qui aime son pays
mais pour celui qui aime le monde entier
merci
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]